your baby knows how to breastfeed from the moment they're born
all babies have this innate instinct called the breast crawl
when babies are born their eyesight is not very strong
so they rely on other senses to find their way to the boob
babies have this innate instinct to crawl towards the nipple
using their sense of smell
get this the body so crazy
mother's nipples literally put out a scent that smells like amniotic fluid
so they're literally following descent that they know from being in Mom's womb
over this process can be totally disrupted
if baby was taken a NICU if babies getting a lot of procedures done
if baby doesn't see mom for an extended period of time
forgot the epidural or Pitocin
your baby is given a bottle or a pacifier
before breastfeeding relationship is fully established
you can run into issues
skin to skin contact is absolutely
essential right after birth with mom
to make sure that we can actually capitalize on this instinct
so our women's bodies innately flawed
or does nature know best and this information is hidden from us